der versuch sich abzuschotten viele
länder machen die grenzen zu
großbritannien dicht aus angst vor einer
neuen virus variante zulassung für
europa die eu kommission und die
arzneimittelbehörde geben grünes licht
für den impfstoff von bayern tag und
weiser urteil lebenslänglich der
rechtsextreme attentäter von halle ist
nach überzeugung des gerichts eine
gefahr für die menschheit
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievert in allen an diesem
montag in der woche vor weihnachten
sport in der sendung nachher mit kristin
otto genannt europa ist alarmiert wegen
einer neuen variante des corona virus
die in großbritannien entdeckt wurde und
möglicherweise deutlich ansteckender ist
als die bisher bekannten die reaktion
der eu so schnell wie möglich abschotten
von großbritannien
und das hat erhebliche folgen viele
länder haben den flugverkehr mit
großbritannien komplett eingestellt auch
die zugverbindung unter dem ärmelkanal
ist gekappt ebenso wie die fähren viele
die nach großbritannien wollen oder von
dort weg sitzen fest
und auch der nachschub der waren gerät
ins stocken anselm stern beginnt seinen
bericht mit der situation auf den
flughäfen in deutschland maschine aus
london gelandet erst einmal zum letzten
mal flüge von der britischen insel nach
deutschland seit 0 uhr heute nacht
verboten
kurz vor dieser frist landen die letzten
passagiere aus großbritannien etwa hier
in hannover
der empfang eine corona teststation und
eine lange wartezeit
doch die ganze nach respekt an die nacht
eine nacht am airport warten auf den
corona test es gab mehrere positive
ergebnisse an mehreren flughäfen unklar
noch ob auch die neue virusvariante
dabei ist die mutation die so viele
sorgen verursacht der pandemie möglichst
aus deutschland und kontinentaleuropa
herauszuhalten
dieser wunsch hat hier ganz konkrete
folgen auf der britischen insel
stillstand im hafen von dover enorm
viele die nicht weiter können weil auch
frankreich seine grenzen dicht gemacht
hat für reisende und für waren aus
großbritannien
das ist der absolute tiefschlag bei all
den schlangen die gegen briggs sind
hamsterkäufen und weihnachten eh schon
hatten es ist ein totales durcheinander
und die lage ist sehr ungewiss
ungewiss unsicher das trifft wohl die
stimmungslage in london und im südosten
englands gelten wieder strenge maßnahmen
die dann auch so aussehen lehre
shoppingmeilen in der mega metropole
london oder so extreme schlangen vor
einigen britischen supermärkten der
premier vor einer stunde die britischen
supermärkte haben robuste lieferketten
jeder kann ganz normal weiter einkaufen
normal lebensmittel einkaufen doch von
normalität ist großbritannien ist
europaweit entfernt das virus und seine
veränderungen bestimmen den alltag drei
tage vor weihnachten oder das
übersprechen mit brüssel und london
gehen zunächst nach brüssel zu stefan
leifert stefan es fällt auf dass auch
wissenschaftler sehr wenig wissen aber
die eu sehr alarmiert reagiert mit
extremen maßnahmen was steckt dahinter
auf einer ersten ebene ist das
tatsächlich die angst vor dieser neuen
virus mutation natürlich ist ja jedem
bewusst dass man dessen verbreitung
nicht einfach stoppen sondern
bestenfalls verlangsamen kann
aber die bevorstehenden feiertag und der
dann erfolgende impfstart sind eine
mischung die sich nicht verträgt mit
einer virus mutation oder einer
virusvariante die dafür sorgen können
dass die infektionszahlen noch mal
massiv nach oben gehen die uhr deswegen
heute versucht ihre maßnahmen zu
koordinieren ganz gelungen ist das nicht
20 der 27 eu-staaten haben zum teil sehr
unterschiedliche maßnahmen erlassen 7
ton im moment gar nichts die eu
kommission ist deswegen aufgefordert
worden bis morgen mittag einen
maßnahmenkatalog vorzulegen der das
ganze dann vereinheitlichen soll aber
das ganze hat schon auch noch eine
zweite ebene dass die eu an diesem sehr
ernsten beispiel vorführen kann was es
für großbritannien bedeutet abgeschottet
zu sein
das kommt manchen hier manchen hier ganz
zupass denn es könnte so die heimliche
hoffnung druck auf boris johnson ausüben
denn so ins stocken geratenen drexhage
rexit verhandlungen doch noch
kompromissbereit zu sein und darüber
nach london diana für großbritannien
kommt jetzt echt alles zusammen
abriegelung eines ganzen landes vom rest
der welt eine neue virusvariante
lockdown eventuell für monate rexit
weihnachten wie kommt dieses land damit
klar
ja das ist ein perfekter sturm nicht nur
für den premier der massiv in der kritik
als er kommt mit den dragset
verhandlungen nicht zu nicht zurande und
diese corona krisen-management dass er
uns seit monaten vor führt steht eben
auch wieder massiv in der kritik es ist
eine weitere kehrtwende johnson wollte
das nicht das ist ganz sicher so er
wollte den briten nach diesem
schrecklichen jahr ein tröstliches
weihnachten bescheren das findet nun
nicht statt und in dieser situation wo
die korona krise mit der praxis krise so
pikant zusammenfällt ist es natürlich
tatsächlich so dass sich die machtfrage
die bei den becks it verhandlungen
wieder hochkommt ganz neu aufdrängt die
machtfrage bei den rechteverhandlungen
lautet wer leidet mehr wenn ab 11
der handel zwischen großbritannien und
der eu auf neue füße gestellt wird auf
welche wissen wir ja immer noch nicht
und dafür das virus eben vor wie sehr
groß britannien und die uhr miteinander
verzahnt sind vor allem aber wie
verletzlich großbritannien von
lieferungen aus der eu ist da kommt
jetzt wirklich einiges zusammen diana
zimmermann stefan leifert herzlichen
dank wie gefährlich ist die neue
virusvariante wirklich
ich kann es sein dass sie auch für die
hohen ansteckungszahlen bei uns hier in
deutschland verantwortlich ist
wir sind eine reihe von drängenden
fragen die sich jetzt stellen pablo
salahi fasst zusammen was wir bereits
wissen und was alles noch erforscht
werden muss
ein zahlencode bereitet europa derzeit
große sorge bei 117 so haben
wissenschaftler die mutierte variante
des corona virus genannt doch wie
gefährlich ist sie wirklich der
chefgeologe der charité
christian drosten warnt vor alarmismus
und verweist darauf dass die mutation
bereits in mehreren ländern vorgekommen
ist ohne große auffälligkeiten zuletzt
in den niederlanden
es muss also in holland schon vor anfang
dezember angekommen sein
es ist aber nicht hochgekocht dort ist
es virus hat sich gar nicht groß
vermehrt und so wird das in vielen
anderen ländern auch sein ich bin jetzt
alles andere als beunruhigt was das
angeht
britische wissenschaftler dagegen
sprechen von einer wesentlich höheren
ansteckungsrate wie jeremy frau als
direktor des wellcome trust einer der
einflussreichsten infektionsexperten der
welt es sieht aus dass es ansteckender
ist und sich in gemeinschaften schneller
ausbreitet auch in deutschland könnte
bei 117 bereits zirkulieren ihren kennen
ja keine grenzen in dem moment in dem
menschen sich bewegen in dem moment
bewegen sich die viren mit und die
wirksamkeit der impfstoffe sei durch die
mutation aber nicht beeinträchtigt
so wie es aussieht ist der impfstoff
auch für die neue
im england japan und das weil die serien
eben auch das neue virus neutralisieren
können als abfangen können
die korona mutation gibt noch einige
rätsel auf aber immerhin bislang gibt es
keine hinweise darauf dass sie
gefährlich sein könnte als die bisher
bekannte und dann und auch das gehört zu
den nachrichten heute steht deutschland
vor den ersten impfungen mit dem
wirkstoff von biontech und pfizer heute
hat die europäische arzneimittel agentur
grünes licht gegeben sie empfiehlt das
serum zuzulassen und diese zulassung kam
vor einer halben stunde von der eu
kommission wenn das paul ehrlich
institut die gelieferten impfdosen
geprüft hat soll es dann ab 27 dezember
bei uns losgehen mit den ersten
impfungen beach area
immer wieder wurde die eu im impfstoff
zulassungsverfahren als zu langsam
kritisiert heute zog das tempo an
soeben verkündete die kommissionschefin
die eu weite zulassung für den corona
impfstoff von biontech kaiser heute
fügen wir unseren kampf gegen kuwait 19
ein wichtiges kapitel hinzu wir haben
entschieden den ersten corona impfstoff
für die europäischen bürgerinnen und
bürger verfügbar zu machen
gerade mal dreieinhalb stunden zuvor
hatte die europäische
arzneimittelagentur ihre
zulassungsempfehlung ausgesprochen
seit anfang oktober werden hier die
studiendaten der impfstoffhersteller
geprüft das wissenschaftliche komitee
der ema ist heute zusammengekommen und
hat eine bedingte marktzulassung für den
von bei on tape von pfizer entwickelten
impfstoff in der eu empfohlen die
empfehlung zielt darauf menschen ab 16
jahren vor einer co at 19 erkrankung zu
schützen
die impfzentren in deutschland stehen
bereit
der bundespräsident appellierte heute in
berlin an die impfbereitschaft der
deutschen
obwohl der impfstoff von biontech
bereits in anderen ländern zum einsatz
kommt sei die eu-zulassung ein
besonderer meilenstein für das deutsche
unternehmen
hier zeigt man sich vorsichtig
optimistisch dass der impfstoff auch
gegen die neue virusvariante wirkt
ich persönlich gehe davon aus aufgrund
der erfahrungen auf und dessen was wir
bei uns dann im stadt wissen
da unser impfstoff an verschiedenen
stellen dieses jahres andauert sollten
einzelne mutation ist nicht maßgeblich
die aktivität des impfstoffs
beeinträchtigen aber nie alles kann erst
dann sagen dann gäste abgeschlossen sind
der weg für die korona impfung ist jetzt
auch in der eu frei am sonntag sollen
die ersten dosen verabreicht werden
und so sieht die korona situation bei
uns aufgrund der gemeldeten positiv
testergebnisse
das robert koch institut registrierte 16
1643 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind 281 mehr als vor einer
woche
2 126 weitere menschen starben mit oder
an dem virus
die zahlen sind montags meist niedriger
weil übers wochenende nicht alle
gesundheitsämter daten übermitteln
die sieben tage incidence liegt jetzt
bei 197,1 der höchste wert seit beginn
der pandemie bund und länder streben 50
an
was bringt der korona impfstoff auch mit
blick auf die virus mutation dazu ein
zdf spezial gleich nach uns und in der
zdf- heute- app neue corona variante was
wir bisher wissen und was nicht alles
zusammengefasst im überblick unser
nächstes thema heute abend eine tat die
dieses land erschüttert hat letztes jahr
im oktober der anschlag von halle ein
27-jähriger mit antisemitischer und
ausländerfeindliche gesinnung will die
synagoge dort überfallen
um ein massaker anzurichten anschließend
erschießt er zwei menschen heute das
urteil die höchststrafe lebenslange haft
mit anschließender sicherungsverwahrung
christoph schneider ein letztes mal wird
der angeklagte am frühen vormittag mit
blaulicht ins gerichtsgebäude gebracht
gegenüber haben sich die zahlreichen
nebenkläger mit transparenten
aufgestellt auch christina feist will
bei der urteilsverkündung dabei sein war
zum zeitpunkt des anschlags in der
synagoge viel anspannung hergekommen
gerade in den letzten zwei wochen im
bewusstsein und im hinblick auf
sich bei mir auch wieder ein bisschen
die frauen symptomatik eingestellt um
kurz nach 11 uhr verkündet die
vorsitzende richterin des
staatsschutzsenats des olg naumburg die
höchststrafe stephan barth wird zu einer
lebenslangen freiheitsstrafe verurteilt
es wird die besondere schwere der schuld
festgestellt und die
sicherungsverwahrung angeordnet
für das gericht ist erwiesen dass der
angeklagte am 19 oktober vergangenen
jahres schwer bewaffnet versucht hatte
in die synagoge in halle an der saale
einzudringen in der mehrere dutzend
gläubige den höchsten jüdischen feiertag
jom kippur begingen 51-fache versuchter
mord
als er an der tür scheitert erschießt er
in der nähe eine 40 jahre alte frau und
einen 20-jährigen zweifacher mord so das
gericht
die ankläger mit dem urteil zufrieden
der senat ist unseren anträgen sehr
weitgehend gefolgt
wir glauben dass das ein angemessenes
und auch wichtiges urteil ist dass am
ende eines prozesses steht das das
richtige signal gesendet hat die
verteidigung hingegen will erst die
schriftlichen urteilsgründe sorgfältig
prüfen
letzter schluss ist kann ich stand heute
noch nicht sagen dass es wochen noch
revision einlegen für den verurteilten
ging's nach dem prozess wieder zurück
ins gefängnis
möglicherweise bis zu seinem lebensende
[Musik]
nachfrage noch bei felix zimmermann aus
unserer zdf rechts redaktion das gericht
ist im urteil speziell auf die opfer
eingegangen welches zeichen wird es
damit setzen
das will damit das zeichen setzen dass
dieser prozess nicht dazu dienen soll
und darf dem täter eine bühne zu bieten
deswegen ist das gericht wirklich auf
die opfer eingegangen hat sie zum
zentralen gegenstand heutigen
urteilsbegründung gemacht hat über deren
persönlichkeit über den leben berichtet
er das leben das der attentäter hier
zerstört hat so dass wirklich die ganze
urteilsbegründung eine
trauerveranstaltung auch für die opfer
war man führte mit als prozessbeobachter
trotzdem blieb diese fassungslosigkeit
auch für das gericht ist sagte wie kann
einem menschen so die herzensbildung
fehlen zu so einer empathie losen tat in
der lage zu sein
anja und für die ermittlungsbehörden
bleibt natürlich jetzt die große aufgabe
solche radikalisierungsprozess im
internet in anonymen foren künftig zu
verhindern
das wird eine große aufgabe sein felix
vielen dank für deutschland und viele
andere staaten steht außer frage auf den
kreml-kritiker alexej nawalny wurde ein
gift anschlag verübt und russlands
führung stecke dahinter
der kreml weist alle anschuldigungen
zurück jetzt hat navalny die aufklärung
quasi selbst in die hand genommen
er gab sich als hoher mitarbeiter des
russischen sicherheitsrats aus und
telefonierte so sagt er mit einem der
täter meinem agenten des geheimdienstes
was für eine geschichte mehr dazu von
andreas künast
seit vier monaten ist alexej nawalny in
deutschland umgeben von ehefrau sohn und
bis zu 15 polizisten seit vier wochen
planten aber nie einen q der beispiellos
frech und beispiellos entlarvend ist
constantin ist dort konstant
die stimme am anderen ende
es ist eine sensation navalny spricht
mit einem seiner acht mutmaßlichen
attentäter mit dem chemiker und
geheimdienstagenten konstantin kuraschew
cf rechercheure unter anderem des
spiegel hatten kurz zuvor die
identitäten enthüllt navalny gibt sich
als rechte hand des chefs des russischen
sicherheitsrats aus und fragt warum der
naughty dog einsatz gescheitert sei wo
war die größte konzentration nun in der
unterhose an welcher stelle der
unterhose die innen wie außen naht nun
man hat die innenseite behandelt ich
denke diese ermittlung dieser recherche
kommt einem rauchenden colts schon sehr
nahe dass das flugzeug mit dem vor
schmerzen schreienden navalny zu früh
gelandet sei sei der eine grund für
navis überleben gewesen sagt der fsb man
die schnelle reaktionen der
rettungssanitäter der andere die
russische botschaft lehnt es ab
zitat inoffizielle
medienberichterstattung zu kommentieren
ganz anderes thema jetzt sexuellen
missbrauch möglichst lückenlos aufklären
damit tut sich die katholische kirche
zum teil sehr schwer
besonders empört sind die betroffenen
jetzt darüber wie das erzbistum köln mit
missbrauchsvorwürfen umgeht kardinal
rainer maria woelki hält eine studie
zurück die wohl auch verantwortliche
klar benennt und jetzt kommen neue
vorwürfe dazu der druck auf den kardinal
wächst dort ferber patrick bauer hat
sexuelle gewalt erlebt jahre lang als
kind durch einen katholischen priester
jetzt fühlt er sich erneut missbraucht
durch den umgang des erzbistums köln mit
den betroffenen
ich habe aktuell das gefühl dass wir
betroffene ausschließlich als
feigenblatt herhalten müssen für mich
scheint ganz klar dass die katholische
kirche immer zu jedem zeitpunkt das wohl
der kirche das wohl von priestern über
das wohl von kindern gestellt hat kölns
kardinal woelki persönlich steht im
verdacht missbrauch vertuscht zu haben
in dieser düsseldorfer gemeinde soll ein
inzwischen verstorbener pastor ein
kindergartenkind missbraucht haben
woelki soll den fall nicht nach rom
gemeldet haben berichtet der kölner
stadt anzeiger
es zeigt sich dass ein system des
verdrängens vertuschens und
verschweigens aus der zeit von kardinal
meisner sich in diesem fall fortgesetzt
hat und das macht den fall für woelki so
brisant denn es wird jetzt immer
offensichtlicher dass er in diesem fall
ähnlich gehandelt hat wie sein vorgänger
woelki hat nun den papst um prüfung der
vorwürfe gebeten und die von ihm in
auftrag gegebene missbrauchs studie ist
weiter unter verschluss die kritik
wächst offensichtlich wollte der
erzbischof von köln über die frage was
veröffentlicht wird die hoheit was jetzt
geschieht macht deutlich es ist
notwendig extern aufzuarbeiten
der umgang mit der missbrauchs
aufarbeitung im bistum köln hat folgen
die zahl der kirchenaustritte steigt
und jetzt etwas ganz anderes in der
sendung einblick in unseren abendhimmel
der jetzt so kurz vor weihnachten ein
seltenes ereignis bietet nämlich ein
wettrennen der beiden riesenplaneten
jupiter und saturn die sind sich schon
in den vergangenen wochen immer näher
gekommen alle 20 jahre überholt der
schnellere jupiter von innen den saturn
und heute stehen die beiden von der erde
aus gesehen fast den einer linie so dass
man sie mit bloßem auge kaum trennen
kann eine planetenkonstellation so hell
vielleicht wie beim stern von bethlehem
sehen konnten wir das himmelsspektakel
in der abenddämmerung tief im südwesten
jetzt sind beide planeten leider schon
hinter dem horizont verschwunden
aber wie gut dass das fernsehen gibt hat
die 19 uhr heute nachrichten
jetzt kommt der sport christin und den
sport das erste großereignis nach
schwierige aufgabe für bundestrainer
alfred gislason für die handball
weltmeisterschaft in ägypten von mitte
januar an ein konkurrenzfähiges team zu
benennen
nach zahlreichen absagen 34 ein 20
köpfiges aufgebot darunter vier
debütanten mit nur sechs europameistern
von 2016 geht der neue bundestrainer
gislason in diese wm
denn es hagelte corona bedingt absagen
der abwehrblock wiencek peking nicht
dabei ebenso wenig weinhold und lemke
natürlich hätte ich lieber den
kompletten kader zur verfügung gehabt
aber natürlich hoffe nicht dass das gut
geht
den wm-kader führt kapitän uwe
gensheimer an dabei sind auch die
erfahrenen keeper wolf und bitter und
vier wm debütanten darunter mindens
junger spielmacher yuri kano die 32 wm
teams werden in ägypten streng
abgeschottet sollen dennoch vor
zuschauern spielen
das hygiene konzertes inzwischen
wirklich sehr überzeugend ist doch
wichtig sein dass alle teilen hier mal
in diesem system geben sich auch an die
regeln halten
in gut drei wochen geht's los die
vorrundengegner sind dann uruguay kap
verde und ungarn die deutschen
ski-crosser in daniela meyer hat mit
platz zwei im weltcup das beste ergebnis
ihrer karriere verbucht in weiteren
frankreich musste sich die 24 jährige
nach einem turbulenten rennen verlaufen
nur der österreicherin katrin ofner
geschlagen geben
zuvor war daniela maier dreimal dritter
geworden und zum fußball hohe strafe für
gladbachs stürmer marco sturm wegen
seiner widerlichen spuck attacke wurde
der 23-jährige vom dfb-sportgericht zu
einer sperre von sechs spielen eins
davon auf bewährung verurteilt die
bender zwillinge lars und sven von bayer
leverkusen beenden nach dieser
bundesliga-saison ihre profikarriere
es sei keine entscheidung gegen den
verein sondern für die familie und die
gesundheit traditionelle ehrung in
baden-baden auch am ende dieses
außergewöhnlichen sport jahres ohne
publikum im saal wurde die welt beste
weitspringerin malaika hamburg zum
zweiten mal nacheinander als sportlerin
des jahres ausgezeichnet
eishockey star lee und drei seite
gewannen die wahl bei den männern und
triple sieger fc bayern münchen bei den
mannschaften und das alles natürlich wir
haben es gesehen auf abstand
ja aber trotzdem mit herzlichen
glückwunsch von uns verbunden vielen
dank christian regnerisch windig und
wenig weihnachtlich sind die aussichten
bis mittwoch pünktlich zu heiligabend
aber ändert sich etwas
katja hornuf er macht es spannend gleich
und jetzt gleich das zdf spezial mit
hanna zimmermann im heute journal ist
die kollegin marietta slomka um 21 uhr
45 für sie da wir sagen danke für ihr
großes interesse und von uns allen
machen sie sich ein sehr angenehm
montagabend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren heute war
astronomischer winteranfang von jetzt an
werden die tage wieder länger
das werden milde windige und regnerische
tage sie sehen wie hier die dichten
wolken aus richtung frankreich und
großbritannien weiter nach osten ziehen
und den strahlenden sonnenschein auch
aus dem nordosten deutschlands
vertreiben
schon heute nacht schüttet es ergiebig
im nordwesten und das bei einem starken
bis stürmischen südwestwind die nacht
bleibt meist mild mit tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 9 und 4 grad und nur hier
örtlich in sachsen thüringen und bayern
geht es ein bisschen tiefer runter und
auch morgen wird es frühling slow uns
erwarten höchsttemperaturen selbst auf
rügen von neun grad sonst geht es über
als zweistellige werte und am mildesten
wird es am oberrhein mit 17 grad
dazu regnet es aber doch meist weiter
bei einem immer noch sehr bögen und
lebhaftem wind aus westlichen richtungen
chancen auf sonne haben sie am ehesten
hier ganz im norden schleswig holstein
und auch südlich der donau bleibt es
sogar trocken
auch am mittwoch überqueren uns in der
mitte und den norden regenwolken bei
immer noch milden 6 bis 15 grad aber am
heiligabend dreht der wind auf nord west
und dann wird es markant kälter dann
kann es schon im tagesverlauf die ersten
schneeflocken in den nördlichen
mittelgebirgen geben
schönen abend noch